[Music]  throughout my life  the ten rings gave our family power  if you wanted them to be yours one day  you have to show me you are strong  enough to carry them  john you are a product of all who came  before you  the legacy of your family you are your  mother  and whether you like it or not you are  also your father  i told my men they wouldn't be able to  kill you if they tried  glad i was right  he's just a criminal who murders people  be careful how you speak to me boys  i thought i could change my name start a  new life  but i could never escape his shadow  my son you can't run from your past  [Applause]  is this what you wanted  [Music]  you got this  thank you  you